this is my home
this is my kitchen
this is my family
Tilly Jack
Holly Megan
and of course my wife Tana
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this series I'm
gonna prove it's still possible to cook
stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
it could be fast it's got to be
delicious
so if you think you can't cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast lunch and dinner
[Music]
today I'm cooking hearty food recipes
with the generous helping of warmth
comfort and Indulgence
it's honest food with big and satisfying
flavors that really grab your taste buds
and makes no apologies so when you want
to welcome your friends or family back
home after a nice long walk or an
exhausting football match these are the
recipes to do it with this is my
ultimate hearty food
first up a hearty breakfast of smoked
haddock with spinach baked eggs
that that's beautiful
for lunch the ultimate comfort of a
hearty creamy tomato soup
that's delicious served with Rich and
delicious Welsh rare bit look at those
babies and just takes cheese and toast
to another level
and my youngest daughter Tilly joins me
making beef and Ale stew with mustard
dumplings
the only way I want you to taste beer
followed by a scrumptious pear and
Ginger galette
three delicious full-bodied comforting
meals breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a hearty breakfast of
smoked haddock and spinach baked eggs
Spokane one of my favorite fish
delicious
highly sustainable it's packed with
protein lightly smoked there's not a Dye
smoke there's a big difference see I've
got that bright yellow tinge
so much better
next baby spinach there's a spinach
that's very young full of zinc great
flavor little teaspoon volleyball knob
of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds I'm cooking spinach and
butter open up the top of my pepper mill
so the pepper becomes almost like so
Cracked Pepper not so fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tag them it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep hold of these and grateful when
you're making a tag of vinegar red wine
vinegar tag and stalks in chop the
tarragon into your creme fraiche little
season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with haddock
incredible this mustardy Herbie creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken the haddock's
starting to flake because it's smoked
lightly cured it Cooks so quickly you
creme fresh
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
let's crack your eggs around the outside
it's a little twist of pepper get the
remainder of your creme fresh and put a
little dollop in between that adds
richness to the egg whites into the oven
at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
it's a professional kitchen chefs refuse
to use the top of the spring onions but
I love that nice dark green flavor it's
less harsh than the white the smell of
baked mustard you can't beat
[Music]
that is beautiful
spinach has almost melted in with a had
it now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
wow
My ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
for my ultimate hearty luncheon dinner
you need some hearty ingredients
here's a more in-depth look at some of
the key ones you'll need to buy
made from roasted malt hops water and
yeast Stout Porter was the preferred
Bevy of London's River Porters in the
18th century
but this bridge bitter tasting beer is
linked with food goes way back too
not only is it the perfect hearty Tipple
to wash down a couple of oysters it
works its magic in soups stews pies and
cakes too
[Music]
classic English ingredients since the
Middle Ages
this hard waxy fat is taken from around
the kidneys and loins of beef or mutton
today so it is still prized for
imparting a unique lightness and Rich
but subtle flavor to Savory and sweet
steamed puddings
and today I'll be rolling up traditional
mustard suet dumplings to hearty up a
slow-cooked beef stew
[Music]
ginger as zingy and versatile medicinal
and Connery heavyweight
used powdered it adds punch to cakes
biscuits and beer crystallized is eaten
as lip smacking sweet meat and the fresh
or pickled fibrous root adds vibrant
heat to dishes the length and breath of
Asia
I'll be using a triple Ginger measure to
give depth and spice to wonderful
classic pear and Ginger galette
[Music]
when it comes to my ultimate hearty
lunch it's got to be soup soup's gonna
be light and delicate or Rich and gutsy
they're versatile practical and easy to
make and for my ultimate hearty lunch
I'm making one of my childhood favorites
roasted tomato soup
beautiful Vine Tomatoes The Ripe in the
tomatoes the better the soup take the
core out get your thumb and place it
half a centimeter underneath the tip of
your knife place it in and then just
twist around that's the only part of the
Tomato that we're not using red onion
and garlic Red Onion because it's
sweeter than a white onion
slice your onions and your garlic
nice and fine
traditionally we make it in a pot it's
so much better to start it off on top of
the stove searing the tomatoes and the
garlic when it goes in the oven you
actually roast the tomatoes and they
don't stew there's a big difference in
flavor be quite generous with the olive
oil it makes the soup nice and glossy
shiny salt pepper and then a little
teaspoon of cayenne just gives it that
heat but it's not as Fierce as chili
take your tomatoes and just slice them
in half
and then
a little touch of sugar that's going to
help intensify the sweetness
a little sprinkle of aged off the
vinegar gives that nice dark Rich
acidity to the soup
into the oven 20 25 minutes 180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
I'm gonna make a Punchy sun-dried tomato
pesto to drizzle over the top
now I'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel so much more in
control and you're not depending on a
blade that's whizzing around at a
thousand miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute Max and then in
smelling there is incredible
parmesan
lightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple of tablespoons of
the oil the sun-dried tomatoes we're in
really helps to make that stunning pesto
I can smell those roasted tomatoes I
want them out
wow
pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those Tomatoes
they break up instantly bring that up to
the boil let it simmer for three or four
minutes
I want to make a little bit more creamy
now
creaming
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and get your Masher in and you've
got that nice thick Rich Chunky Tomato
Soup or please help a stick blender
blitzing it like that you deglaze the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty I'm going
to knock up a deliciously gutsy version
of cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup whilst rabbit an absolute classic
I'm gonna make a roux 50 grams of butter
three nice tablespoons of flour and
that's all the roux is basically
traditionally you would use flour butter
and milk
but in Welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout it gives it that strong gutsy
flavor
I want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of Dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy Worcestershire sauce
gives it that delicious intriguing
Flavor now that smells amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now boss rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
Welsh rabbit without Rich mature cheese
soap and a great
Montgomery cheddar goes well with the
beer
and drop that in really important to put
this in by the roux is still nice and
hot because the cheese melts
now for the bread
I prefer good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
I want that nice crisp base to my Welsh
rabbit so toast it both sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy Berry spicy
mixture just great
got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
God
a little splash alien Perry
and back under the Krill for 90 seconds
in one delicious creamy roasted tomato
soup it's coming back to me all those
days I had off school I used to
purposely lie about feeling ill just to
get a bowl of my mother's tomato soup
how bad was that but my God it was worth
it oh
now or Welsh forever
[Music]
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious Welsh rabbit
I feel like ringing in sick
[Music]
next up Tilly and I cook a Hearty dinner
that would leave even the hungriest
giant satisfied a soothenly scrummy beef
stew with mustard suet dumplings how's
that taste now hmm not loud anymore
and for deliciously satisfying pudding
pear and ginger galette look at that
baby that looks good
[Music]
[Applause]
some of the best hearty dinners I can
think of are slow cooked recipes made
with robust deep flavored ingredients
and left to Bubble away for hours until
they become glossly rich this is the
sort of food that really gives you
plenty of energy and protects you
against cold winter weather so for my
ultimate Hearty dinner I'm doing a dish
that every home cook should have a
recipe for a great stick to your ribs
stew here's my favorite beef and Ale
with mustard dumplings
foreign
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest Tilly
Tilly first things first I'd like you to
season the stew and stay
a nice spoon of flour
yeah good girl what's the flower going
to do dad the flower helps to Brown the
beef our seasoned flour will also help
to add flavor and thicken the stew
I feel a bit like marshmallows you do
feel
look at the size of the chunks of the
beef
I'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar sizes right does that
mean they'll cook equally that's right
now these are little pearl onions I'm
going to put them in whole as well
everything
has to stay the same otherwise it could
burn oh we've seen burn garlic before
Oh Matilda
she promised you weren't going to
mention that
what is that
time time and what they
[Music]
Bailey's Bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in the beef goes in first okay in
a beautiful color
remember the carrots thyme in good girl
garlic pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
oh that's too easy to make Daddy his
shoes are very easy to make providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love
now that's all juicy browned
that's it that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or Stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor and that's the only way I want
you to taste beer
in this chair
yeah
point that in a couple of teaspoons of
tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice and there's one
final thing in there cover this tuna
steak with a big stock give that little
mix of Danny please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you start um serve it
oh yes is the Garlic going to be burnt
no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe that's right not make the stew
or watery into the oven at 150 please
tell us for about two and a half hours
and now
getting focus on your homework
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato Classics in one twice baked
bubbling squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute and butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and
cooked through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato Center
then Mash with a couple of knobs of
butter or mix in the cabbage and season
to taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato Classics in
one twice baked bubble and squeak jacket
potatoes
homework done yeah exterior stewing
stewing let's get on with our delicious
hearty pet tart I've been looking
forward to this you and I Chef I'm gonna
prep the pears so if you peel I'll top
and tail into quarters pears go soft in
the oven very very quickly so we're
going to put them on a tart you'll need
to leave them whole half or a quarter
what's that in there
Ginger that's right that's stem Ginger
so when you use stem Ginger and fresh
ginger next add your stem Ginger a
little of the stem ginger syrup good
girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
then just cracked some fresh ginger off
you go so it's a bit of a different one
to grate this because
it doesn't really come through like the
cheese no
I'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there right what we need to do
now is give that a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff we can make it so easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point I want you to get
the pears get around
like that with a really nice Circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
so egg wash the outside and I'm going to
show you a little trick so you lift that
up
like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
the pastry forms this nice little shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
building that up then you see
the fresh ginger and those nice little
bits of stem Ginger let me go round my
leg with your glue we might glow just on
top
Tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glazes the pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top
180 and then she goes
you smell the beef
wow it seems it seemed down a bit more
I want you to just I was hoping you'd
ask
but it will taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
not allowed anymore
dumpling time flowering please I'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour next The Dumpling essential
suet that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round Another
Touch of warm water here your fingers
are now a nice little whisk fingers are
getting tired right now put your hand in
there and I should bring all that dough
together
I'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off
that's a good way is that now but it's
wonderful dumpling mixture how squid is
that
a little flower on your hands okay roll
these lengthwise
and then I want you to follow my lap in
your hand
I'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on you never trust you with
something like that
yes please
tell me
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center and put that back into
the oven for 20 minutes to cook the
dumplings now if you open the door for
daddy I'm going to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
has had 35 minutes in the oven
look at that baby
good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please nice and gently all the way
around good girl
little taps the others are gonna love
this it looks a bit like a snowy cake
doesn't it good job now very carefully
carry that
to the table
how nice does that look the list okay
I'll check on the dumplings
now look
they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
I might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check I mean we'd
have to be sure we have to be
[Music]
ready
the twice baked loaded potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate Hearty dinner a
comforting Rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and Ginger galette
ready for some delicious beef stew yeah
oh wow thank you very much delicious
thank you will we be able to heat this
up for mum and Jack when they come back
easy even two or three days later tasty
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
next time vegetarian Delights Fit For A
Princess
[Music]
as I prove breakfast lunch and dinner
can be just as mouth-watering wow
without the meat I don't have any
problems turning vegetarian when I'm
having muffins like that
[Music]
this is my home
this is my kitchen
this is my family Tilly Jack
Holly Megan
and of course my wife Tana
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this series I'm
going to prove it's still possible to
cook stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
it could be fast it's got to be
delicious
so if you think you can't cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast lunch and dinner
[Music]
packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food I think
every home cook needs recipes that don't
just taste delicious but satisfy the
soul too the type of food that wraps his
arms around you and gives you big hugs
so when you want to give your family and
friends a big serving of Love here's my
ultimate comfort food this is guaranteed
to make you feel cozy even on the
coldest of days
first up at breakfast that will bring
you a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast for lunch I'm pulling
out all the stops with a fantastic Twist
on one of Britain's favorite comfort
dishes ginger beer battered fish with
chili minted mushy peas It's Gonna Do It
do it properly for dinner my youngest
daughter Tilly is in the kitchen and we
share the secret ingredient in every
comfort food dish happy memories
[Music]
when she made them for you always such a
hot pot with beetroot and potato gratins
on the menu for dessert spiced apple
compost silly we're on for a treat this
is my ultimate comfort food breakfast
lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on you my sneak
a couple of sugar lumps from cafes and
put them in my porridge without him
watching these days my porridge has much
more flavor than just salt it's packed
with fruit nuts and spices add vanilla
seeds to porridge oats or oatmeal it's
really important just to rub the vanilla
through the oatmeal makes it nice and
fragrant now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that smells incredible I quite like
making this up week at a time and
Jack absolutely loves it now whole
almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pot in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
I'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge and then a couple of
minutes before you go to bake it add
your cream
now
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes has this really
nice rich crust on top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top now bake at 180 for 30 to 35
minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally for three to four minutes
look at that that makes me feel proud to
be Scottish because it's perfect for a
big Comfort family breakfast it's Rich
it's Sumptuous and it's just a humble
oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
[Music]
next I'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food I crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
My ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage I grew up on the classic British
Banger made with ground pork salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and I'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch I'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in Southeast Asian
cooking grape seeds made from those
yellow flowering crops this has the
lowest saturated fat content of any oil
and has a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
a good cheap all-rounder with a neutral
flavor is vegetable oil which is the
blend of oils like corn soybean and
sunflower
[Music]
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from China but today in
Britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the UK
are Braven and Gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp Bramley which I'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food multimet
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas I've loved it ever since I was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks
for my Ultimate Fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of Ginger to go with it
chili minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm the secret is to season
the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that'll keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic nah the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour I want a bit of heat in the batter
so a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then
two teaspoons of baking powder this
almost lightens the lower the batter now
ginger beer it gives that batter the
sort of unique spicy individual flavor
it's delicious for the fish and a nice
tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
Sheen
give it a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of double cream
too thin and The Battered runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
its magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish
it's gone slightly firm
perfect for fried start by coating the
fish in flour seasoned with pepper hats
that nice and dry into your hands so you
haven't got any excess flour the flour
stops the batter from running off the
fish I'm just gonna check to see if my
oil's ready by putting a little touch of
batter into the fryer
if you see it bubbling straight to the
very top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist your pan
that stops IT from sticking at the
bottom oil should be gently sort of
bubbling away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish fry the fish for three to five
minutes gently turning halfway through
once the batter's golden and crisp it's
ready look they look stunning it's like
these big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured Cod leave the fish to rest on
the kitchen towel to blot excess oil and
meanwhile it's quick and easy chili
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
nice
knob of butter into the pan
shallot finely chopped that adds a bit
of sweetness to the peas slots into the
pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy they're even
better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infused
with their perfect partner fresh mint
stalks on all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the peas I've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
I love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
Crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed delicious peas
those peas it's incredible
chopped mint
chili minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
if you're going to do it
do it properly
oh
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
Crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic Rosemary and Thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
coming up it's dinner time and my
youngest daughter Tilly and I are
cooking up food to make your mouth and
eyes water let me give you a little
taste of that
thanks for the warning as I give my
family A Taste of the comfort food of my
childhood when I was yours guys Nanny
was making this for me and then those
days you would ride to school on
dinosaurs
not loud
[Music]
[Applause]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells from the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
I love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and I hope it will always remind my kids
of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood is my
youngest daughter Tilly
My ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage Hot Pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
I just love having them with the baked
beans and times we've been sometimes on
top these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
look at the hall and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today
school was good thanks we got to go out
and make snowmen sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
darling
see
now
want you to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
now
sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one none
used to make for me yeah once you've got
the color on them
and take them out
the rest okay
a little knob of butter okay into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so they'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor
smells nice washrooms in give them a
nice little stir
would you like to help me make your hot
pot when she made them for you I used to
always help now make the hot pot always
now my mum would never have used this
but age balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
her onions look beautiful caramelize the
vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss I'm gonna put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
look beautiful smell
the ball really important to boil it
here because it won't boil in the oven
170 in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly sliced potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
they're incredibly acidic okay and you
need to cook them those wonderful red
apples you've got are called Bray Burns
what other apples do you know cream ones
what are they called
um
oh what the green ones another word for
your nan
Grandma's no
red no Pink Lady apple no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apple that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
replace it quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay nice golden color cinnamon ginger
in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook them to the apples soften
then take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out Dan so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
the gingers I'm gonna take
a spoon of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the color of the apples hmm
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top
you separate the egg whites into there
for Daddy
right egg whites are in separate
foreign
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
good girl
[Music]
please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff Pig so you lift them
up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree
and you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just nicely fold that in
so we bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep good girl
silly we're on for a treat open up the
Piping Bag
Now do just the end
now you could spoon this in I don't want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern lemon on top
fridge the beetroot and potato gratin is
that lovely that's lovely sausages
finished with the flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it it's one of the best hot
pots
ever actually that looks amazing
I know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple compart
food with guaranteed feel-good Factor
mommy Jack Holly Megan
[Music]
it smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorites so
tasty I love it it is so good I love the
mushrooms as well that is so nice and so
simple when I was your age guys Nanny
was making this for me in those days the
sausages weren't as fast
excuse me I'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
next time Tilly joins me in making my
ultimate picnic Fair
three amazing movable feasts to keep you
energized for Alfresco fun morning noon
and night
[Music]